[Music]
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup
i'm rachel dempsey i'll be your host for
today's rn supply chain meetup
i'm joined by my colleague and co-host
for today curtis kephart if you want to
say hello as well curtis
hi everyone
and we're also joined by our two awesome
speakers for today laura darby rose and
ralph asher
if you just join now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window as well and say hello
maybe include where you're calling in
from
but just to go through a brief agenda
while we wait for a few others from the
waiting room
we'll go through some introductions of
the meetup
have two awesome presentations intro to
supply chain design with ralph asher and
forecasting demand with r
with laura rhodes
we'd like to also use today's meetup to
kick off a supply chain working group
too
i mean curtis kephart from our team will
give us
some more information on that and how to
join if this is something that's
interesting to you
and then lastly we'll open it up for
additional audience q a and just open
discussion among everyone
i did mute everybody upon entry right
now but towards the end we will
unmute
but if you do have questions during any
of the presentations we do have a slido
link that you can use
um so you can ask anonymously or include
your name there as well
and we'll share that in the zoom window
right now
that will really help us to organize
questions too and you can upload
people's questions
and just a quick note that the recording
will be shared up to the rstudio youtube
as well so
if you want to share it with anyone or
go back and listen later
um that will be shared up there
one other housekeeping note if you want
to turn on live transcription during the
meeting you can do so as well and that's
offered in the zoom bar below
and
curtis if you could go to the next slide
awesome for anyone who's joining for the
first time today i'd love to welcome you
to this meetup group this is a friendly
and open meet up environment for teams
to share the work that they're doing
within their organizations teach lessons
learned
network with others and really just
allow us all to learn from each other
so thank you all for making this a
welcoming community
i really want to create a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so we want to reiterate that we love to
hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience in the field as well
if you ever have suggestions or general
feedback
or want to speak at a future meetup i'll
share a few links in the chat window
right after this as well
but with all that i would love to
introduce our first speaker today ralph
asher
ralph is the founder of data driven
supply chain
and prior to founding data driven supply
chain ralph ortez operations research
scientist in corporate supply chain
functions
at target and general mills
and so with that i will turn it over to
you ralph
all right thank you rachel for the
introduction uh hello to everyone who's
on this webinar wherever you may be just
reading through the chat sounds like we
have a global presence already and
that's great i really appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you today as
mentioned my name is rob fasher and
today i'll be talking about supply chain
network design what is it first off and
how can we use open source languages
like rn python to design supply chains
so i'll share my screen and hopefully
this will go off without a hitch
all right so a little about myself like
many on this call i have a math science
background i have a bachelor's in
physics and
a master's in operations research i
started my career after college in the
military i was on active duty in the
marine corps for several years and i've
been serving as a reserve reserve marine
in a part-time capacity for about 10
years since then
uh after military i worked in supply
chain design and simulation for eight
years at general morrison target here in
beautiful cold minneapolis minnesota i
left the corporate world last summer to
found my consultant firm if you're
interested more learning more about that
please reach out in addition to running
my company and serving in the marine
reserve i'm also an adjunct at the at
the university of
minnesota business school where i teach
statistics
i've been an r user for 10 years since
2012 and i've really found the language
to be an ever
increasingly versatile
tool for my work
i've also loved maps and math and
programming since i was a little kid so
i'm kind of fortunate that i've found a
career field that lets me merge these
interests
so supply chains from the back office to
the front page uh the covet 19 pandemic
it's really caused unprecedented
disruption to global supply chains
manufacturing shutdowns as well as labor
shortages and a dramatic shift in
consumer spending from services to goods
have caused massive disruptions to the
previously invisible flow of materials
this disruption can be seen in the
container ships waiting off the coast of
southern california awaiting the dock in
los angeles and long beach
it can be seen in the reconsideration of
reshoring american manufacturing
capacity or the delays in building or
repairing homes due to supply shortages
it can be seen in the inflation that you
see at the store shelves and at the gas
pump
and even santa claus can't fix these
problems
and he has the most advanced logistics
operation known to mankind or elfgand
instead the task of ensuring supply
chains continue to function so we
literally have food on our plate and
fuel in our cars
that falls to the legions of hardworking
supply chain management professionals
and as a data scientist i'm really quite
proud to be able to use my quantitative
and technical skills to help these
efforts
so you may be asking yourself how can
analytics be used in the management of
supply chains uh depending upon your
background this slide may be old news to
you but i find it's useful to discuss
supply chain analytics in the framework
of descriptive predictive and
prescriptive analytics
now descriptive analytics the biggest
and most important part of the pyramid
includes business intelligence and
diagnostic analytics of the supply chain
how many of my trucks arrived on time
how productive were my manufacturing
plants in my warehouses how are these
metrics trending and are any of them
worrisome
predictive analytics is next how do we
predict what's going to happen next in
our supply chain that includes things
like sales forecasting as as we'll be
discussed next as well as forecasting
cost of your supply chain inputs and
some types of supply chain simulation
finally the top of the pyramid which by
volume should occupy the least amount of
time is prescriptive analytics uh what
should i do with my supply chain
this is my wheelhouse and includes
things like splatter network design
discussed today
as well as inventory optimization and
other types of supply chain simulation
now a key point for this audience
especially is that open source
technologies are really changing the
landscape in supply chain management and
splatch analytics when you look at each
of these capabilities you can mentally
pick out which are python packages you
could use for them
this really is a sea change for when i
started in the supply chain analytics
field about a decade ago
when the toolkit consisted of excel for
data analysis
spss for statistics and commercial
visualization software like tableau
so what is supply chain network doing
plainly it's the strategic analysis of
the locations and activities of the
various elements of the firm supply
chain for example if i'm a manufacturer
where should i locate warehouses for my
raw materials the stuff i use to make
other stuff or my semi-finished goods
which are items that are only part way
through the manufacturing process where
should i put my manufacturing facilities
my plants where should they go
where should i put my distribution
centers my warehouses for finished goods
where should they be located
and if i'm a retailer how should i use
my stores as a link in my supply chain
for example many many leading retailers
including my former employer target
use their stores as strategic assets for
shipping e-commerce orders well from
where should we do that that's a big
question that's a supply chain network
design question
supply chain network design seeks to
answer these big questions all with the
intent to understand the impacts on
profitability cost service and other key
metrics and with the goal to minimize or
maximize one or two key metrics usually
cost or profitability
today i'll be focusing on a relatively
simple example of supply chain network
design a distribution network with two
echelons
the distribution centers or warehouses
and customers that are serviced by those
warehouses
in designing the supply chain we ask
ourselves given a customer base of
demand aggregated to a city level
one where should we open distribution
centers to satisfy that demand
and two what customers should be
serviced by or aligned to each
distribution center
while most real-life supply chain design
problems are much much more complex in
this example
i hope it will be informative on how
practitioners approach these kinds of
problems and how we can use open source
technology for them
so how do we do this uh how can we
answer these questions we can answer
them with optimization modeling
optimization modeling is a mathematical
technique that allows a practitioner to
optimize a set of interconnected
decisions
where the decisions are constrained by
real world limitations
optimization solvers take the decision
options formulated as a mathematical
model and return the set of decisions
that optimizes minimizes or maximizes
an equation that includes the decisions
as inputs this equation is formally
known as an objective function
if anyone on here has an operations
research background i realize it's not
the precise mathematical definition but
i find it to be useful in explaining the
field
so in our case the decisions we need to
make are one how many distribution
centers to open and where should we
locate them and to what customers to
align each distribution center
you can see that these decisions they're
interconnected because i can't align a
customer to a distribution center in a
certain city unless i also open a
distribution center in that city
and the limitations on our decisions or
our constraints uh they're one that all
customer demand must be met
we may have a minimum or maximum number
of distribution centers
we may uh really only realistically open
distribution centers in certain
locations so we have to start with kind
of a candidate set of cities
we may have a maximum volume per
distribution center that's also called
the capacity
and
for certain reasons we may put a maximum
distance between a customer and its
servicing distribution center and we'll
see that later in an example
so we'll shortly transition to the shiny
app i built for the webinar but first
i'll introduce the scenario now because
this is a simplified scenario this is a
simplified version of an app i would use
for a regular project
you are a supply chain data scientist at
heartland widgets incorporated
your company is the market leader in
widget sales across an eight state area
of the american midwest the pandemic can
do shift in consumer demand from
services to goods as well as statement
stay-at-home orders has led to a boom in
demand for your company's flagship
product the at-home widget
faced with record demand the director of
supply chain network planning has asked
do to quote reimagine the company's
distribution network
you are to recommend the uh where to
open hot launch distribution centers as
well as the customer to distribution
center alignment to achieve a minimal
cost
artland widgets has customers in 117
midwestern cities
spread from the dakotas in the west all
the way to my home state of indiana and
the east
each city's demand is proportional to
its population so for example chicago
illinois which is a big city you may
have heard of it has more demand than
fargo north dakota
heartland is considering 20 cities for
potential distribution center sites
because each distribution center will
cost 1 million dollars to open
it may not be cost effective to open
distribution centers in all 20 cities
but we're keeping our options open
so let's get a little bit more technical
here
the decisions we need to make for
heartland widgets can be represented by
variables when we ask what customers
should we align to which distribution
center this is equivalent to asking a
set of yes no decisions that must be
made in concert
for each customer city i should i
service it by a distribution center in
city j yes or no
and making our decisions we're limited
to having exactly one yes per customer
city it has to be serviced by exactly
one distribution center
relatedly we need to make decisions
about how many distribution centers to
open and where to locate them
this is a series of if-then decisions
related to our alignment decisions
if at least one customer is aligned to a
distribution center in for example omaha
nebraska
then we must open a distribution center
in omaha
the decision sets are interconnected we
cannot separate our decisions on where
to locate our distribution centers from
our decisions on how to align customers
to distribution centers
mathematical optimization and more
specifically the techniques of linear
and integer programming are ideal for
making these kinds of interrelated
decisions
when we use mathematical optimization
including for supply chain design we're
trying to minimize or maximize some
equation that is the function of our
decisions
in this example heartland widgets wants
to design the supply chain with the
lowest total cost the supply chain costs
in this example are one the opening cost
for distribution centers which are
priced at one million dollars each
to the handling costs of the
distribution centers which is one cent
per unit per widget
and three the transportation cost from
distribution centers to customers which
are five cents per unit mile now a unit
mile
is moving one unit one mile so for
example if you have two widgets two
units and you move them 100 miles that's
two times 100 200 unit miles at five
cents each that's ten dollars to move to
two units 100 miles
you add up these three components cost
components and it leads to the total
supply chain cost that we're trying to
minimize
now one of the tenets of supply chain
design is that these cost components
can be inversely related to each other
for example the more distribution
centers you have the closer you are on
average to your customers
and if you're closer to your customers
on average you're going to spend less on
getting the product to them on that
transportation cost because it's just
closer
however uh the more distribution centers
you have the more you spend to open them
in the first place so there's an inverse
relationship between the distribution
center opening cost and the
transportation cost to get the product
to your customer the more distribution
centers you have the more cost to open
them and the less you spend on the
transportation inverse relationship
optimization modeling helps us figure
out these relationships and help and
find the optimal solution that takes
into account the relationships between
the costs
all right so because this is an r meetup
and i'm going to demo a shiny app
i want to go over the packages i used
this is a tidy verse centric solution
for dataprep but i also use dt data
table and room
shiny dashboard is used for
visualization and i use our hands-on
table to allow for interactive
adjustment to input tables
leaflet is used as a mapping solution
and the core of the optimization
modeling rests with the ompr package and
the open source symphony optimization
solver
as an aside the coin rr foundation the
organization that maintains symphony and
other open source optimization tools
like pulp and payomo for your python
users they need financial help
please consider donating via that github
link
all right from here i'm going to work
from the app
but i have slides for backup in case of
technical difficulties i host my app on
shinyapps.io
you'll see the address but to avoid
having technical issues i'd ask that
you know nobody try to load it while i'm
giving the demo
all right so
this is a pretty sparse app
because it's a fairly simple example
and
first step is
uploading our data so
we really only have two sets of input
data
our customer information and our
distributions and our information i've
prepped the data
so
i'm going to use room here
and these are small files but even if
they were large they'd still upload
pretty quickly because we're using brown
then
saying yes it's going to be used
all right
so now going to inspect this upload data
and talk a little bit through it
first our customer data
so our customers are as mentioned 117
midwestern cities
and for each of these we have city name
state latitude and longitude their
demand which is proportional to their
population
and then we have this column called
maximum miles to distribution center
you'll see later on in the in an example
how we would use this essentially if you
want to enforce a maximum distance from
a customer to the distribution center
that services it you would set this
column to that distance limit
right now i don't care about that so
i've set this number so insanely high
that it doesn't really matter
finally we have this column called
include and this is a nice thing about
using our hands-on table because you can
actually dynamically update the table
that you use later on in your app
so
everything has a check mark here if i
unchecked any of these they would not be
used in the optimization model
so i'm going to display the customer map
you see these 117 cities across the
midwest
and just as an example of how our hands
on table works
i wanted to get rid of rapid city south
dakota you see it's down here
now it's gone but i do care about our
rapid city so i'm going to keep it back
all right so that's how we're using our
hands-on table for the customer inputs
distribution center similarly we have uh
20 candidate cities across the midwest
and uh
for to put our distribution centers in
we have a latitude our longitude our
capacity which is the maximum volume
that it can be have aligned to it this
is effectively infinite compared to our
customer demand
because it's a very very high number
each of them costs uh one million
dollars to open and our handling cost is
one cent per unit
as mentioned earlier
and this check mark allow essentially
says do i want to consider this location
if i unchecked any of these
that location would just be taken out of
consideration right away
so finally we have our some inputs here
before we run the optimization
so i mentioned earlier that you can put
a constraint around your minimum and
maximum number of distribution centers
and so
i'm going to start off by saying i'm
going to have a minimum of one i need a
warehouse somewhere
and a maximum of 20. because there's
only 20 options here having 20 is your
maximum is kind of like saying i'm
willing to take any of them
the transportation cost for five per
unit mile is five cents as mentioned and
these are some more technical things i
won't get into
all right
so when i click run optimization what's
happening now is
my app is taking the customer
information the distribution center
information
and the
maximum minimum number of distribution
centers
and forming an optimization model on the
back side on the shiny app server
it then finds the optimal solution the
minimal cost
and returns me uh returns the the
outputs
luckily it worked as fast in this demo
as it has in my practice
all right so
let's look and see what those optimal
solutions are so
to service all of our customer demand
for heartland widgets
the optimal lowest cost solution is four
distribution centers one in omaha
nebraska one here in minneapolis one in
chicago and one in my old hometown
indianapolis
you can see
the
cities that are serviced by each
distribution center are represented by
their color you know red for omaha and
blue for indianapolis green for chicago
yellow from minneapolis
and they're
kind of geographically separated as we
would kind of expect
because you generally want to have your
customers closer to your distribution
center
this table is an alignment table which
is just the tabular version of the map
that we're seeing above so for example
ames iowa
which is over here
is serviced by the distribution center
in omaha nebraska
the farthest distance from a customer to
its servicing distribution center is 415
miles and that's from rapid city south
dakota over here all the way to omaha
take note of that uh because we'll
actually come back to that in a little
bit
so what is the optimal cost here
the total supply chain cost uh that can
be the minimal supply total supply chain
cost in this scenario is 7.5 million
dollars over here
that includes four million dollars in
distribution center opening cost one
million per distribution center and four
of them
thirteen thousand dollars for handling
at the distribution centers and about
3.5 million dollars in transportation
cost
so our total 4 million plus 13 000 plus
3.5 million equals 7.5 million dollars
and that is our absolute lowest total
cost
now i'm going to make a small detour
before we get into another scenario to
explain more what we mean by constraints
in supply chain network design
in optimization modeling constraints are
mathematical limitations on what set of
decisions you can make
that correspond to real life limitations
the more constraints you have in your
model and in real life the worse your
objective function becomes so in this
case the more the supply chain cost
would be
optimization modeling including supply
chain network design is an exercise in
understanding the trade-offs involved in
making constraints more or less
restrictive or tighter or looser which
is the term apart
in designing your supply chain the
tighter the constraints the higher the
total cost becomes supply chain design
is partly an art around understanding
the additional expenses associated with
tighter constraints
next we'll talk about what a couple of
those constraints may look like
so
first we see that the lowest total
supply chain cost occurs when we have
four distribution centers in these
cities up here
so what will what would happen if we
actually force our model to have exactly
three distribution centers how will that
change our cost how will that change
what our network looks like
this is actually quite straightforward
to see
all we need to do
is go back to our minimum maximum number
of distribution center constraints
so
i'm going to change the minimum to three
and the maximum to three because these
are integer values by forcing your
minimum and maximum to both be three
you're going to end up with three
distribution centers
and click run optimization
again and this optimization model is
just running in the background with the
additional constraint that it needs
three exactly three distribution centers
i'm going to go back to my results it'll
refresh
and now we see that
instead of four distribution centers we
have the required three
and
it's the same layout except now
indianapolis is gone sorry to my who's
your friends
and so
question then
what does this do to
our overall cost because as i mentioned
the tighter you make your constraints
the worse your objective function
becomes in this meaning the more you're
going to pay on in
total so let's look at these outputs
our dc opening costs are now three
million dollars because we only have
three distribution centers and they're a
million dollars a piece
our handling cost is the same because
it's the same for all distribution
centers and we have the same amount of
volume
but our transportation cost which was
3.5 million dollars before is now 4.6
million dollars
so while our just our distribution
center opening cost went down a million
dollars
our transportation cost went up
one million one hundred thousand dollars
and so our total cost went from five
seven point five million
to seven point six million
so we see that this one change increases
the cost now a hundred thousand dollars
is a lot of money to a normal person uh
in the consideration of a base of 7.5
million it's not a big difference but it
is an increase
so that's what we see when we
just force exactly three distribution
centers
next we'll see what happens when we
enforce a maximum distance constraint
between our distribution centers and our
customers
this is often the case with food supply
chains
because food is perishable and you don't
want your food outside of a climate
controlled warehouse for too long before
it gets to a store
and so often times when designing food
supply chains you would put in a
distance constraint
this is actually pretty easy to do with
our ant on table and using this maximum
miles to dc column
i'm going to say a maximum of 400 miles
between all of my customers and my
distribution centers as you may remember
the distance between
rapid city south dakota and the
distribution center in omaha nebraska
was 415 miles
so by adding this additional constraint
that alignment is not possible it's not
going to be allowed
so we just change that column
changes back to 1 and 20
and run optimization
i'll give this a few more seconds if it
doesn't work as quickly as i thought
i'll just go to my slideshow
okay
so
instead of weighing that we'll just go
back to the slideshow here so
what would happen if we did force a
400-mile constraint
is that instead of
you know we'd still have four uh
distribution centers as the optimal
setting
but instead of a warehouse in
omaha nebraska we would have it in sioux
falls south dakota
why because that is the distribution
center that allows sioux falls which is
a sorry rapid city south dakota over
here which is a very remote
customer to be within 400 miles
and the impact on the cost structure is
that instead of
instead of 3.5 million transportation
costs we now have four million dollars
in transportation cost
so by adding that additional constraint
around 400 miles from your distribution
center to your customers
your total supply chain cost rose from
7.5 million to 8 million
let's say we actually wanted to see
the overall total cost at different
number of distribution centers
i went and ran this model
forcing it to have exactly one
distribution center
exactly two distribution centers three
distribution centers all the way to nine
i then recorded the cost components
between the handling cost the opening
cost and the transportation cost
the handling cost in green is flat no
matter how many distribution centers you
have because it's the same volume just
split in different ways
this blue line is our distribution
center opening cost which is linear
because with the more distribution
centers you're spending another million
dollars
your transportation cost in red goes
down
because as i mentioned the more
distribution centers you have the closer
you are on average to your customers so
your transportation cost goes down
it goes down dramatically from one to
two distribution centers but then kind
of flattens out so there's not as much
of a benefit
so your total supply chain cost which is
this purple line
is kind of a parabola
and the minimal cost occurs at four
distribution centers as we saw before
but between for example two and five
there's not a tremendous amount of
difference
and so if i was doing an actual study
for a client i'd be presenting something
like this and saying actually while four
distribution centers is your minimal
cost network
between two and five there's not much of
a difference in cost and there's pros
and cons of each of this
all right uh
well that's most of the content folks so
i really appreciate your time today i
just wanted to wrap up by saying and
emphasizing that supply chain management
really
was a behind the scenes corporate
function until the beginning of the code
with pandemic but now it's front page
news uh we all see it
and analytics powered by open source
programming languages it really is
changing the nature of this field
supply chain network design uh it's kind
of obscure part of splash and analytics
but i find it to be a powerful tool
devising and evaluating the organization
supply chain strategy and hopefully
today you just got a taste of what that
might
look like
and uh thank you for listening uh if
you'd like to know more
please reach out
awesome thank you so much ralph
um and i just wanna
that was a great presentation great
presentation i just want to reiterate to
everyone i see a bunch of questions
coming in through the zoom chat as well
if you could use the slido that would be
super helpful so we can kind of help see
the questions versus comments in the
chat
but ralph i'd love to ask a few
questions that came in on slido now and
then we can hold a few others until the
end as well absolutely
um but one i see that was from jerry um
that is how large of a problem can the
open source solvers handle from your
experience how often do you encounter
models that would require a commercial
tool
uh yeah i mean i can speak in
generalities i found that it's more just
a question around what size of a machine
you put it on
i've ran some pretty large optimization
models on open source solvers
and if you have the right hardware
and you know you're kind of paying for
it in your time or you're paying for it
in your dollars and so if you're willing
to wait you know an hour longer than you
would otherwise it's well worth it
um
i haven't in my
both in my consulting and my corporate
work i have not encountered a size of a
problem where an open source solver
couldn't handle it
just like wooden
compute
thank you
i see cynthia had also asked the
question
do these optimization packages allow for
optimizing to more than one success
metric at a time
like cost plus customer satisfaction
yeah yeah and so
you can kind of shape your objective
function
to reflect whatever combined metric you
may care about
so
in this case the objective function that
you saw was purely a cost function
but i've in the past done things like
well
here's my cost and here's for example a
customer service metric that is also a
function of my decision variables and
you can weight them now when you see the
output
it's a number it doesn't really reflect
like you know dollar bills on the table
or anything like that but it can kind of
uh in the more heavily you wait
cost versus customer success or customer
satisfaction
that uh
that combined metric can can lean
towards one way or the other
great thank you
and i know a few people had asked this
and were curious about the shiny code
that you used and if you would feel
comfortable
sharing your slides as well as maybe
some of the shiny code
uh i'd be comfortable sharing my slides
uh unfortunately not not the code uh
that's kind of a trade secret thing but
and one one last question and then again
we'll cover additional questions at the
end as well i'm just excited to get to
laura's
talk too
um but the next question was how did
your optimization run so fast are you
using parallel packages
uh
i mean it's partially running so fast
because it's a small example problem uh
but no i'm not doing any parallelization
or anything it's just running on my on
whatever machines getting spun up on
shiny apps
thank you so much ralph for a great
presentation and
i know there's a bunch more questions
here as well that we'll cover at the end
and something i should have noted from
the beginning is
in slido if you wouldn't mind maybe
saying who your question is for so at
the end it will be easier to separate
them out for ralph and laura
but with that i'd love to turn over to
our second speaker laura darby rose
laura is manager of demand at malin rock
pharmaceuticals where she's responsible
for statistical forecasting forecast
visualization and forecast accuracy
measurement
that i'll turn it over to you laura
thank you rachel
okay so um i'm going to talk about our
experience at melanchrot
with forecasting demand and r
so
we went through a project about a year
ago to replace a
software as a service i will not name
that company
my boss has advised me to not name it
with a an open source r solution
so a little bit about my background
i'm a demand manager as rachel mentioned
and i work in the supply chain
department
and in melanchol we have a couple of
different divisions so i work for the
specialty generics division
and we make basically generics that you
might be prescribed when you go to
a doctor or your nurse practitioner
wherever you might go to see so a lot of
pain management acetaminophen
other things as well
so my main job responsibilities
are stat forecasting and then measuring
forecast accuracy so
not just
of the stat forecast but also
our commercial partners provide a
forecast based on kind of market
intelligence info that they've collected
um they do not do
stat modeling as far as i can tell
but they do submit a forecast
and then i wanted to add um
a caveat here that i only had about five
months of experience regularly
programming an r when i started the
project
and i share that with you all to
hopefully encourage um people who are
just getting started in r
or python and you know thinking about
doing
a project that will really
involve um
r or python
if you know enough to write a script you
probably know enough to do a
a project that would really impact your
company
and i guess i didn't put this on the
side but i'll mention it since i know
ralph mentioned
academic background i am an economist by
education
i've worked most of my career
in supply chain and really did a little
bit of economic consulting but found
that i really enjoyed supply chain so um
here i am
okay so how the project began
so
imagine it's spring 2020 actually you
don't have to imagine right uh it's
probably all still fresh in our minds
and you're staying home
um being a good citizen and you're a
little bored so
uh what did i do um created a little
shiny app a simple shiny app for time
series forecasting
and a shout out to the our ladies
organization i actually got the
inspiration for the app from our ladies
st louis meetup
and um so i use the materials that the
presenter had provided to kind of dig
into shiny i'd taken a few online
tutorials and shiny but never really
done much with it
so you know i'm working remotely
and i want to impress to my manager that
hey i'm being productive so in one of
our calls i stood in the app and um
he was impressed with it and he thought
well maybe we can replace the sas that
we were currently using for stat
forecasting with this app or something
like it
so the sas that we were using
um cost about two hundred thousand
dollars per year
which for my company is
not small change we were definitely in a
cost savings mode
it was also generating negative number
demand forecasts so keep in mind that
that's
what do you even do with that right
um we're not gonna we're not gonna sell
a negative number
um the it support for this company could
not figure out what was going on so it
was costing us like a lot of time and
effort
to basically
modify these forecasts
so um after my manager's initial
approval um
i collected some demand data we we chose
about 30 skus that we thought were
representative of our
of the business
and i did a rolling forecast accuracy
analysis we wanted to have an idea
before we proceeded further what kind of
accuracy we could expect if we switch to
the our forecast package that was what i
was using at the time i'll go more into
that a little bit later
and
specifically the ets function which is
the exponential smoothing commonly used
in univariate supply chain forecasting
also the arima function
and there's um options there for
um just best fit algorithm kind of a
thing
so the ets function was actually
comparable to what was used or what we
had enabled in the sas
various exponential smoothing models
were selected by the demand forecaster
so i ran this
rolling forecast accuracy analysis
and uh to get give you an idea
of how
uh
perhaps not efficient i was at the time
and i'm sure i'll be saying the same
thing about myself in a couple years
today
but uh i i had three for loops that i
used to do this and anybody who's
programmed in r for
a while knows that's generally not the
best strategy but it did work and uh we
we
were satisfied that hey just doing like
setting the ets algorithm to best you
know best fit minimizing the aicc that's
the akaike information criteria and the
corrected one
that was comparable to what we were
getting in terms of forecast accuracy
from our sas
also the benefit was hey we didn't need
manual intervention from the demand
analyst or manager
so we made the decision
to move forward with this project and
then we had to get the buy-in from the
it group that at malinka not the of
course the it support at the sas company
since it was in their budget
well as you can imagine um it wasn't
difficult to get buy-in for a cost
savings project
um they were also frustrated with the
lack of support that we were getting
from the sas company
and the time required that we were all
spending on doing useless tasks
so up till then i had written some other
scripts that i used for various data
wrangling tasks the kind of stuff you do
in supply chain analysis right in demand
planning which is my specific area
of expertise
and
we didn't want to just have me running
scripts on our studio desktop as useful
as the free version of our studio is
we wanted more enterprise capable
options so
we looked into our studio server pro and
i believe the most recent version of
that is called workbench i'm not super
up to date on that
then we also contracted with lander
analytics
and they helped with server setup and
maintenance and then application
installation so it is a linux server for
those of you might be more windows
people and at malinkrat we're more of a
windows shop is what i've been told by
rit group so definitely need a little
bit more guidance in setting that up
and we had both a production and dev
server that were
supported with them
okay so
we're moving forward in this project we
made the decision to go forward
the itt analyst
who was responsible for maintaining the
data used for stat forecasting needed to
collaborate with me to replace the data
management so not the forecasting
but those of you who might have used a
sas at your company for forecasting or
other other things note that it the sas
can sometimes do functions that are not
just the main function that you may have
purchased before so we needed to do
in-house solutions um
especially generics is kind of old
school in a way so we have like an as400
system
so we needed to create a bunch of tables
make sure we were maintaining those
tables jobs were running that kind of
thing
so we had a tables for both um cleansed
history and non-cleanse history so
cleanse being removing outliers
sometimes you might decide to not
include all history for consideration in
the stat forecast model because there
might have been a structural change
something like that
so we wanted to move away from excel
spreadsheets there was definitely a time
and a place for spreadsheets but um we
just didn't feel that was in the best
interest of the business so uh we we use
the dbi package which probably many of
you are familiar with and then the odbc
package um lowercase odbc i think
there's a uppercase r odbc package
and just using some basic sql we got
those set up and it was very easy to um
connect to the as400 system pull in
those tables that i would need to
estimate models and calculate forecasts
we also changed our outlier cleansing
process as i alluded to in the second
point um and that is because we had
previously cleansed the history directly
in the sas application so we just moved
to a pretty simple process we were
trying to come up with something in the
limited time we had
and uh we we had an excel upload if you
needed to remove an outlier you'd upload
an excel file to
our as400 system so probably could have
been well we're changing the process
actually now and i'll get more to that
in the future but you know it worked in
the initial stages it worked and
sometimes you have to go with that
and then we also needed a table to store
stat forecasts generated from the r
script so
as i said before no excel files involved
we were going to write that to
a table and then we also needed another
like a file or table so to speak for
storing historical forecasts and that is
to measure forecast accuracy
okay so we were able to use rstudio
server pro for other uses besides stat
forecasting so i alluded to earlier in
my presentation i had written other r
scripts to do a lot of data analysis and
wrangling tests the kind of things that
you don't want to spend a lot of time on
if you can um
measuring weighted mape we measure
weighted mape is what we use to measure
our forecast accuracy there are other
metrics that your organization might use
um checking the commercial forecast
upload versus the download
um
i am responsible for loading the
commercial partners forecast to the erp
system and depend depending on how
things go
um we might have kind of phantom
forecasts hanging out in the erp system
so
it's hard to check that in just doing
spreadsheet analysis but it's it was
fairly simple to write a program that
did it in our
also um
last year with the pan well as i said
last year i guess this
two years ago almost now
we had a lot of order orders for
acetaminophen with the start of the
pandemic
and
our product director needed some help in
understanding how to allocate
um
orders and versus forecast so we have
some amount of product and based on the
forecast the customer provided they were
either going to get product or have to
kind of go to the end of the line so to
speak
and there were some other ones i won't
for the sake of time i won't uh bore you
guys with the details of those so it was
very it was simple to set these jobs up
to run on the server using cron r and
that's um as you would expect by the
name it's an r package which interfaces
with cron
so the script saved a lot of time all
these jobs set up
we could compile a lot of data reports
no intervention or maybe a little bit of
just give a
give it a you know check from demand
managers
and then the real test is when i was out
on short-term disability um this past
summer
the jobs ran well
they saved my co-worker a lot of time
having to cover you know my
responsibilities as well as his
so my co-worker left the company
november so i've since been taking over
his former duties
and i've been uh writing various r
scripts to kind of hopefully improve
some of the processes and it really has
made it possible scheduling these these
jobs on the rstudio server
pro interface has really made it
possible for me to do my job as well
well as his previous duties
okay to summarize the project
you're probably wondering how long did
all this take
um it took about 11 months and i will
say this um
you could probably do this kind of
project where you totally replace the
software you've been using
um in less time
we happened to have a lot of time based
on when the contract with the sas was
going to be up and so we had several
months in early 2021 where we were
running both concurrently
there are definitely improvements to be
made to the forecasting processes and i
can tell you that as well as anybody at
the company
um that's what i deal with day in and
day out
but the initial goal of replacing the
sas with solution at least as effective
was completed so we consider that the
initial stage to be a success
we measure on the lag three forecast
accuracy which basically um takes into
consideration essentially it's
sort of like lag four you think about it
takes history from four months ago when
you're measuring the particular month in
question
but it's been about the same depending
on the month a little bit worse a few
percentage points but we did meet our
goal for 2021 so my boss is happy i'm
happy
and the cost savings is definitely worth
it for a slight trade off in accuracy
and we are still using pretty simple
models like you know
arima exponential smoothing models so we
hope that as we introduce new models um
we will improve accuracy over time
and then i alluded to this earlier
in the presentation so i started out
with the forecast package in summer 2020
and then i found out
i guess it was probably old news but it
was new news to me at that time about
the tidybirt suite of packages which is
kind of the replacement for the forecast
package
and so i switched to that i switched
over the code that i written to that
and took a little bit to kind of make
sure i understood everything but it's a
great great suite of packages that
includes fable feast
civil um
civil data i think
so i have found those to be really
useful for automatic forecasting if you
have a lot of skus and you don't have
time to go in and like tweak parameters
you know figure out the best arriba
model figure out the best exponential
smoothing model for instance like
univariate forecasting um the models
they produce the forecast for supply
chain are stable forecasts
they don't require a lot of intervention
you're not going to get anything
unbelievable or
crazy i guess
okay so
i mentioned the shiny app earlier so the
impetus the project started with a
simple time series forecasting app
we made the decision to forecast the
script scheduled as a monthly job
instead of an app
and part of the reason for that was it
seemed simpler at the time
time savings
also it ended up working out we weren't
really ready to go with our studio
connect at the time which we would have
needed to host the app for an enterprise
um in an enterprise capable way
so after that i developed another shiny
app kind of based on the first one
which is more uses a number of different
packages the tidy birds packages of
course dt i think ralph mentioned that
in his app to edit history you can
change parameters um basically
interfaces with our as400 system via sql
so you can for the app you can
interactively like edit our um our data
in our company's systems
and this allows me to especially for
those high volume really important skus
to go in and pick out specifications i
think are optimal so we're hoping that
this will give us more opportunity to
kind of
tune a better model for um the skus that
we consider to be you know a skate is
important
this the impetus for creating this app
was actually my former co-worker um and
he wanted something that mimics some of
the functionality that we had in our
previous sas so he liked being able to
go in play with parameters kind of test
things out see if how if you change the
history how does this change the
forecast that kind of thing look at
different accuracy metrics as he was
creating his forecast
so future state
it's always good to be thinking about
continuous improvement right so i'm
working on um
another shiny app to visualize our
generics data that's our finished dosage
data um with the pivot table probably
using the pivot table
um package not sure yet i might look
into a few other packages
and then we either look at monthly or
weekly doses
or bottles depending on what the user
would want
so i currently use this very slow tool
using a legacy system i will not name
and uh
we use this for creating those
visualizations for the demand review
slide deck where we look at our customer
demand compare that to our um
look at our forecast see let's change
look at our financials that kind of a
thing so this will help me
more than anybody else but i'm
definitely interested in improving my
processes
and then another project we started last
month is
looking at the commercial team forecast
so they currently don't use much
statistical forecasting
so they are interested though in looking
at their end purchase or demand and how
we can roll that up under
distributor customers uh malin cott is a
manufacturer so we sell to some big time
distributor customers you may have heard
of in the news
and there's certain customers that are
pricing contracts and then those
distributor customers are sell to you
know more of retail pharmacies kind of a
thing
so we're hoping to get a better picture
of our demand to kind of tie that out
and
build a better forecast for them in that
way
and then in terms of model improvement
those of you are familiar with the tidy
verts packages
probably know that you can do
hierarchical forecasting as well
we did explore that a little bit in the
initial stages of the project excuse me
when we were trying to understand what
we wanted
how
how much we wanted to experiment with
different kinds of models my boss
thought it wasn't a good idea at the
time but now that we've completed the
initial stage we'll probably look into
that a little bit more and then also
machine learning methods for time series
we would need to do that on weekly data
we don't have enough monthly data really
to make it worth it but model time is a
good package so
that's um
that is something that probably this
year we are looking into exploring
so to summarize um
i just a lot of this on this slide is
common sense but i think it's probably
worth reiterating
you're interested in doing like a
project where you replace a
you know assass with
an r solution start sooner versus later
something that we
learned sometimes the hard way is that
the sas will perform other functions
besides forecasting
um so you need to come up with solutions
for data storage and management and
those solutions might not be are
specific but they need to be compatible
with
you know whatever you're doing and are
for forecasting
so you might need to create a database a
data warehouse maybe you already have
something like that at your company or
your organization
also project management um 101 i guess
make sure you've been estimate the time
involved on your part as well as many
collaborators because
you you don't want to come up to the end
of the project and figure out that they
don't have enough time to give you
to complete the project
and then i wish i somebody had told me
this ahead of time learning some project
management skills is helpful probably a
lot of us on this call are have good
technical skills
um i when i was trying to map out this
process which is my
um subsequent point i i had really no
idea what i was doing and it it got done
but it could have been a lot a lot more
efficient
okay and then
i feel like i i might be a little bit of
a broken record here but
you don't want to realize you haven't
accounted for something you previously
relied on the sas to do when you've
almost completed the project
and as you probably expect we learned
that the hard way there was my co-worker
used the sas for something i did not
exactly know what he was doing and i
think there was a miscommunication
between perhaps an i.t um analyst and
him
not just throwing blame but we realized
oh we never accounted for this now it's
we're practically finished with this
project we need to make sure we have
something that will allow him to do what
he did with the sas so
you don't want to you don't want to have
our experience there
and then i i'll finish um hopefully this
is not too uh pessimistic with nope but
with a paraphrasing of murphy's law if
something can go wrong it will so plan
for all the contingencies and since
we're all in supply chain planning that
shouldn't be too hard
okay that's all i've got uh questions i
guess rachel
um i don't know how we're gonna yeah
i cannot i can help with reading this
but thank you so much laura that was an
awesome presentation really appreciate
it
i see a lot of
great comments in the chat as well and
just want to remind people if you could
use the slido link to ask questions that
is super helpful for helping us organize
them
[Music]
but i i did see one question that just
came through quickly on the chat was
if you could please repeat the name of
the package that you used which allows a
user to edit data interactively oh sure
sure dt but i know and ralph mentioned
this in his presentation
our hands-on table is another good one
and there are other ones out there i was
familiar with dt and i already gone down
that path um so i was just like i'm
sticking with it if i was building it
from scratch maybe i'd do our hands on
table but yeah there are several good
packages out there
cool thank you
um another question from slido was what
type of data are you forecasting on
invoice sales demand
demand data so we have two divisions um
yeah invoice sales um
yeah it's it's by request date so it's
not shipment it's supposed to be a
representation of what our true demand
is so not taking into account any supply
supply issues so we sell business to
business so we we supply um
a lot of the pharmaceutical companies
you probably heard of in the news
and i that's all i can say about that
and then we also supply some um you know
distributor pharmacies that's our dosage
product so the kind of stuff that you
might
get prescribed if you you know for pain
management or
other
conditions
thank you
um but laura one question was if you had
unlimited budget would you prefer one
modeling an r and then passing results
to
tableau or two modeling and displaying
in r and shiny
so r and chinese is a clear um
a clear winner for me so i have used a
um commonly
oh i i
i can't name names but a commonly used
data visualization tool which is uh
um
kind of a click and drag and everything
and i just don't find it i like to know
what's going on behind the scenes
and you know when i'm writing that shiny
code i know how things fit together
but when i'm doing if i was just being
more in tableau or another uh
i wouldn't you know and i know there's
beautiful visualizations that can be
done in tableau but i wouldn't have the
same sense of control so that's that's
my personal preference and i'm not
saying it's the only it's the right one
thanks laura
um and i'm gonna try and also pull
people into the discussion and
allow people to unmute yourself i know
this is dangerous with 300 people but
eduardo i saw you had a great question
that you put into the slido as well i
was wondering if you'd want to read that
one out loud and add some context there
and i can start by reading the question
too
um but it was
laura did you have to deal with
uploading
back the forecast to erp
if that was the case were there any
guidelines you had to follow with it
um so you're talking in the stat
forecast i assume i mean i know i
mentioned doing a check of an upload
so i'm assuming you're going with stat
forecast here because that's what we the
models estimated then calculating r so i
actually worked the nice thing about
designing the system on your own again
maybe i'm a control freak but i hope not
um is that i had a chance to work with
the it analysts and he and i have a very
good working relationship to say okay
this is the kind table we want to build
i need this field i need this field i
need this field so we kind of had a
custom solution built um
i think within my we use within the
service account which we use on our
studio and that's so it's not tied to my
personal account so any it can run if
i'm on short-term disability or whatever
um
there i think we had to have like
permissions edit set so that anybody
could you could write with that account
to the table that's a you know pretty
simple fix though so no they were they
were based like what do you need from it
and i was like here's what i want here's
why i wanted they said okay
great thanks laura
one other question that came through on
slido was how do you store snapshots of
your forecast for later accuracy
analysis
okay yeah i kind of did allude to that i
guess
so we are um
we every every this is something that i
t team handles i guess i could
theoretically do this and r but
at the end of the month um before the
table that receives the forecast um
is
is cleared that that forecast so all 67
000 now lines of it or whatever we
forecast three years out
no that's just nothing magic about three
years that's how we do it um it's copied
to another table that has i think we
store 13 months of historical forecasts
and then when i measure um statistical
map the script pulls in from that
historical table and filters i use um
some of the the dbi interfaces and
there's in the parameter argument you
can say i want to pull in based on this
criterion and you pull in whatever might
be your lag three forecast or lag one so
that's how we measure it but yeah we do
track our
stat forecast accuracy uh pretty
carefully
great thank you so much laura
and i see there are a ton of questions
that have come in here too so a few of
them don't say if it's for ralph or
laura either um or or both so i'd love
to
throw some questions at you as well
ralph from earlier too
but one was
ralph what are packages do you use for
operations research optimization
problems
yeah so for optimization uh the biggest
ones i use is the onpr
which stands for i think optimization
modeling
process and r i'm not sure about the p
but uh
and essentially it's a pretty intuitive
way to take linear program or integer
program optimization models and
formulate them in our
and that's kind of
modeling language package
and then there's some adjacent packages
that actually then send it to the solver
of your choice and so if you go on the
packages
github site it's it's very easy to read
but i like that because
it's it's built with a tidy verse
centric mindset
so for example you use pipes to add
components of your model and you can do
whatever code you need to do to prep
your input tables and then just send it
into your optimization model which is
how i'm able to kind of dynamically
change the inputs and then re-optimize
on the back end so that's that's
probably what it is
great thank you
um and one other question for laura and
then i'll turn it over to you curtis and
then we'll kind of go back to open
discussion and remainder of the
questions
but the question laura was thanks for
the inspiring presentation how did you
manage our package updates in your
organization
um and did the it admin control the
package updates
that's a good question i'm trying to
think um probably the first thing is i
should become clean that i probably
don't update my packages as
often as i should i am actually the only
user
of r in my division i'm not sure about
we have specialty brands too so in terms
of managing across the organization it
hasn't been an issue at this point if we
do bring on another um analyst or we
have a current person who learns r and
kind of decides to do some stuff with it
that'll probably become more of an issue
but i do use um this isn't quite exactly
your question maybe it's helpful
i use uh
r3 no i feel bad admitting this but
3.6.3 for some of my scripts i know i'm
really
but then i use 4.1.0 for stat
forecasting because we do use parallel
processing for part of that and it's
just
the time difference was we were getting
timeout issues it was just really a big
difference and when you set up a job
um you can specify which version of r
you want i want to use that's not a
package question though but you can use
both that's nice
awesome thank you laura
and curtis said i'd love to turn it over
to you to have you kind of give us some
more information on the working group
that we're trying to form as well
and to kind of get us all thinking about
what resources maybe we might want to
contribute there too
yeah thank you thank you everyone for
presenting and we'll get back to the
questions in a moment but we also did
want to take an opportunity with this
with this group
um you know there's there's obviously a
lot of interest in combining open source
software plus to solve the problems that
folks in supply chain management have
um the the kind of too long didn't read
or didn't listen version of what i'm
about to say is if you if you consider
yourself kind of one of two people uh
either keenly interested in kind of
community organizing for supply and
drain management or keenly or interested
in contributing uh resources to the
community whether it be our packages or
articles kind of sharing uh best
practices that other people could
benefit from i really encourage you to
have a look at the link that i just
shared is an rstd.io link have a read
over the kind of proposal we we present
there uh and you know consider
participating and and you know
submitting your name the longer version
is right there's a lot of interest in um
supplier management plus open source
software and so you know rachel ralph
and i had talked a couple months ago now
actually about kind of how to take this
community to the next level um there's
certainly a lot of industry groups as
well as you know field groups that have
uh you know set
kind of templates that communities could
follow so you know i have a lot of
colleagues in r pharma for example they
have a nice conference that brings
everyone together and shares resources
a lot of groups create shared packages
uh with kind of common solutions uh
there's a lot of ways to approach it um
you know we we propose um a working
group to kind of create a community hub
for you folks where you could share
resources and share best practices that
you would all then be able to to benefit
from and develop together
um so again if you kind of consider
yourself one of those two groups i would
really encourage you to have a look at
that link and consider
submitting your name what we do after
that is we'll follow up shortly after to
kind of bring those folks together and
continue the conversation about how to
take this community to the next level
the other thing i didn't mention is i'm
curtis i work at our studio i'm
community organizer i've been with you
guys with our studio for a while and you
know been watching the community grow
for for years so
super happy to be a part of this
thank you so much curtis and if anybody
has questions about that too or
um please
feel free to even raise your hand on the
student call or reach out to me directly
too
but i see curtis you shared that link in
the chat there's awesome
i know there are a ton of questions
still on slido so i can go over to those
two
but also
if you're
if you're here and have a burning
question that you love to ask live as
well feel free to raise your hand on on
zoom 2 and i can call on you
laura one other question that was on
that looks like i came in pretty
recently was
did you experience any challenges and
change management when it came to
convincing stakeholders to use the
analytics tools and forecasts
no i didn't and that's because it was
less work for pretty much everybody um
yeah so if you can make people's lives
simpler it's very easy to get by and if
you can convince them to do that i was
recently on a call with the director of
i.t as well as my boss who's the senior
director of supply chain and the
director of rt was like yeah it's saving
us 200 000 a year it's less work for the
it analysts and
he's like yeah it's been great we've you
know
um so
i think my old co-worker
he
i think liked have having not to do as
much work because i also had some r
scripts that did his mate processing and
other things for him helped check his
uh forecast upload that kind of a thing
so make people's lives simpler and they
will be happy to change in my experience
i love that
and i see one of the most upvoted
questions right now is i hope you got a
raise for the 200 thousand dollars in
cost savings
i i think it's uh i did get a raise yes
and a promotion so
congratulations
um so a few
other questions here so for ralph there
was one
how do you incorporate uncertain inputs
like laura's demand forecast into models
to be run in deterministic solvers
yeah it's a great question so
this is kind of where the art and
science come together
and so there's a couple ways
the way i primarily like to use is
essentially use
a simulation to
change the inputs so for example
if the demand for ames iowa was not this
number but rather we think it's from
here to here
you kind of do a sampling
of each of those you run the
optimization and
overall you do this a bunch of times to
kind of compare the outputs and see
how different really are the
recommendations like if it's always
recommending these four warehouses
those four warehouses are a good choice
if there's radically different outputs
then you kind of gotta dig a little bit
deeper
thanks rob
and i see
another question was um
could you it could be for either of you
but could you talk a bit more about
compliance um
for an in-house application
yeah rachel or sorry uh laura would you
mind taking that
sure yeah um so compliant my i'm not
sure i entirely understand the question
if you if you are able to get a little
more color and put that in the chat or
somewhere else um perhaps rachel can
give me some insight into that
because we use statistical forecasting
we were using it i was going to say it's
more of a benchmark for our commercial
partners um
there wasn't a lot of compliance
presenting out pharma especially opiates
which is the um
the one of the products that melanchrom
makes it's very highly regulated as you
know
but
the commercial teams their forecast has
to submit a lot more customer level
evidence to the dea for quota um for
statistical forecasts we're basically
saying what does our demand say so there
wasn't as much of a compliance issue
and my company i will say for being a
fairly large organization people are
pretty agile about hey if something
works and we like it we're going with it
as long as we're not obviously breaking
any laws or you know circumventing
regulations so if you have any more
compliance with it i see someone says
compliance with i.t standards
um yeah i mean they were
i guess maybe i'm being i'm very
fortunate to have a night a really chill
it team but they they were like yeah
let's go for it it sounds good as long
as i get the time to do it which they
they did so
and then i see someone else say
compliance my financial division will
kill me if i do that
well i mean i go back to my previous
comment
if you can simplify their lives maybe
they would reconsider so
hopefully that's helpful
i like that that idea of simplifying
others other people's lives
to push things forward
um another upvoted question was what
metrics do you use to measure forecast
accuracy and i'm not sure if we had
covered this at all
yeah i guess i briefly touched on it in
my presentation we use weighted mape so
that's that's how we define that there's
a couple different definitions but it's
basically the sum of all
of the absolute variances so at we
measure at a skew level you can do it at
different levels um
forecast minus demand or absolute work
estimates demand over the sum of all the
demand so that it essentially gives more
weight to um
higher you know higher volume skus
uh relatively speaking i mean i don't
it's all aggregated but
we don't really pay attention as much to
those little volume skus because hey if
they're really accurate or they're not
they're absolute variants it's never
going to be that that big so
thanks laura
and i know i mentioned this before but
if you have a question and you want to
ask it out loud too feel free to raise
your hand on zoom or even just unmute
yourself and
and jump in i i know it's very hard to
recreate that in-person feel virtually
but would love to hear from
you all
um i have a question sure go ahead
so
i am looking into breaking into the r
scene but i have like a little bit of
experience prior experience but not not
much
how do you recommend i go into this
should i just start learning r first
like the syntax and all that and then
doing project or should i just dive
right in and start doing projects that i
can find plenty of on kaggle
i'm happy to take this ralph if you want
to chime in i feel like i've been
talking a lot but i'm more i you have i
have less experience than you so maybe
it's
more recent in my memory
yeah i'll okay i'll give my then i'm
sure raffle has some interesting things
to add
i would say you want to be at the level
where you can at least understand how
functions work you can i mean tidy verse
is really kind of an i know people like
data table too i personally am not
familiar with it
um but tidy versus kind of an essential
i would say
for supply chain you know you're doing
all this data analysis and manipulation
wrangling all that kind of stuff
you should be able to comfortably write
at least a fairly a simple r script
um
and you do learn as you go along
sometimes the best way to learn is to
actually pursue something
i think once you have a deadline that's
where all becomes real you know so make
sure that you've got something working
before you can't give the cancel notice
to your sas or whatever else you're
going to be doing that's going to like
be involve money on the line i guess so
that's my advice but yeah i mean if you
can write a simple r script you're
probably ready to start some kind of
project
go for it
yeah i'd concur i mean vast majority of
work in supply chain is data prep and
data analysis so if you can start with a
kind of a tidy verse education that's
probably best and then
just learning functional programming
from there is good
thanks val
i'll read one of the slido questions to
you but again
raise your hand on zoom too if you want
to jump on no question oh there you go
yeah i have one question yeah so uh yes
ma'am for forecasting uh for forecasting
in a
like
weight weight
uh in a forecasting in a supply chain
system uh there isn't forces for
forecasting matter like time series
forecasting econometric model uh
judgmental forecasting and delphi method
so which is adopted for the precise
outcome
so judge metal forecasting really
wouldn't involve any statistical
modeling per se you would kind of just
say i think this is best that's that's
kind of
somewhat of what our commercial partners
do i think they do some trending and
things like that i
have not quite gotten a super clear
explanation which i will probably be
learning more about that as they
uh go into this project with them um
delphi method if i'm my memory serves me
accurately and someone feel free to jump
in on the chat if i got this wrong as a
kind of a consensus panel of experts
um
and
that i mean that would probably more not
fall under this kind of project and
there might be some products for which
you want to do that um
but that's not you know at the middle
level manager
high level analyst data scientist rule
that's probably not what you would be
doing as much unless you maybe you could
put a variable in the model that
you know i'm just brainstorming here
that would account for that
but i don't i don't i'm not involved in
that in my company
i see todd has asked a question on slido
that was um is the distance calculation
line of sight or road network based what
options are available to the solution
i think that'll be for you
yeah uh yeah so it is uh line of sight
uh just kind of as the crow flies for
speed uh you can certainly do road
distance calculation and use it it's
just a distance matrix as an input and
uh so like for example you can use uh
there's some open source options for my
work i use google maps api
because that's kind of the gold standard
of quality and it's quite easy to use
but yeah you can do it either way in
this particular demo it's just straight
line
uh
rachel i see something from a zohan in
the chat that i wanted to
address she said to her microphone or he
or she the microphone is not working
correctly special so the question is um
how do you handle special events like
promotions and advertising your stat
models so
their company runs a lot of promotions
but not during the same months so this
is a case where you would definitely
probably want some sort of time series
regression model
in in generics we cannot do promotion so
we can't say hey we got a hydro
promotion going on obviously the ea
would
not like us if we did that so um if in
that kind of an industry like a consumer
packaged goods perhaps or something you
it you could if you had a um a forecast
from there was going to happen and then
maybe a past time series of that you
would want to put that as an explanatory
variable in your model
i see one from yoni how do you describe
your clients counterparts
what factors are driving your
optimization forecasting models this
might be for both ralph and i um
let's see
i
my
counterpart well it's just me in demand
planning now so um my boss and i he's
got a pretty good technical
understanding of things the big concern
at my company and this is not every
company is forecast accuracy so if the
accuracy is good
if i could be doing the most complicated
machine learning model that anybody ever
thought of they would they would be it
wouldn't make that much of a difference
but i do realize that that's not the
same for everybody else so uh ralph you
probably have a couple things to
to add about that
or
adjust about that
yeah i mean it's largely saying okay
here's how
here's how our model solving is is
happening like what's underneath the
hood in the business sense you know
here's the three cost components here's
how you might see the trade-offs um
sometimes there's it gets a little bit
tricky because sometimes you see outputs
that oh that doesn't make sense well it
actually does once you take into account
all the constraints and things like that
but you just need to
hopefully build the credibility first
that they can take the hand wave
explanation at that point
um i know we're getting to 30 minutes
past the hour um so we have a few more
questions here and
i know a lot of people have to drop but
i do want to say if anybody wants to
stay on and just kind of chat with each
other we could we can stay on
past the time too
and maybe pretend like we're all in
person
but uh
one of the questions was how have you
dealt with time series model forecasting
when there has been such a large change
in values for example the price of
things
so that's a really good question i would
say if you have pricing data you could
put that like price elasticity of demand
you can put that as an explanatory
variable in your model i was dealing
with univariate here and univariate is
not always the best choice if you have
things that correlate well
in my company we have pricing contracts
our price actually does not um change
very much and i think our
commercial team is not particularly they
don't like to change price very much
which means if you don't have enough x
variation in your data it's not going to
be a good you know you don't want it you
wouldn't include in your model um
so
let's see i think that mostly addressed
it addressed that but yeah if you i mean
the moral of the story is i think i
probably maybe sound like a broken
record here if you can do
um you know a regression or some other
type of model where you have you're
bringing other factors do it because
you're probably going to get some more
information there if you find of course
good correlation between the outcome and
the predictors
thanks laura um ralph i see you had
answered this on slido but someone
really wants to know that this and i see
a few questions coming in with this
um which optimization algorithm did you
use in your app
uh so it's a mixed energy linear program
for those who are familiar with
operations research terminology uh
essentially
use the ompr package builds the model uh
based on your parameters and then sends
it to a solver and solvers uh
a lot of people dedicated people work in
those but essentially it uses a lot of
different approaches to solving the
problem and
picks the best one essentially
great thank you
um
mohit i am apologize i'm pronouncing
your name wrong i see you had asked the
question or i'd raise your hand as well
if you want to jump in
yes so my question was regarding the
correlation factor correlation analysis
which laura was speaking about like
if the price is correlated with the
demand like you just put it as an
external variable so does that require
any
analysis beforehand you put in those
external variables or you could just
dump all the variables you are thinking
which might be correlated and let the
like uh just the algorithm decide which
ones are best and
so what is the correct approach ask for
your experience i just want to ask that
good question i thought i could teach a
class on that and um it's funny you you
bring this up because i see um someone
federica hey federica i think she's
still on from my book club islr um that
i'm in where they talk about different
models or different ways to select your
best you know the variables you want to
include i mean a correlation matrix is a
good you know first start obviously if
you see something that's not highly
correlated you may
want to consider dropping it um
academics versus business people
approach things a little bit differently
in terms of how how they would think
about a model and report that i'm
assuming your prob might be in business
i don't know
um
but yeah you could there's different
methods um maybe i should say join the
islr book if you want to find out some
more about subset selection
but uh correlation is a good way to get
started and then think about does it
have any theoretical basis right if it
if it does then maybe you should include
it at least try it out in the beginning
but without seeing data it's kind of
hard for me to give a more
in-depth answer so
hopefully that helps you out
thank you so much laura
and i i see there is also another
question that is what is the best way to
connect with both of you laura and ralph
after the meeting if people wanted to
ask follow-up questions or connect is it
linkedin
yeah linkedin or email
linkedin is fine i i think a lot of us
get a lot of spam in our inbox by try to
respond to messages that don't look too
spammy um i think my email might be on
my linkedin um but yeah you're welcome
to email me uh i mean i'll try to
respond i'm actually pretty much you can
email so
but
yeah feel free to feel free to
discuss there's the um isn't there the
chat supply chain on the r
r for data science slack too if you're
you're interested that's a good
um
i mean it's not super active but there's
no reason why i couldn't be more active
definitely i was just going to mention
that too so after the first rn supply
chain meetup
we did make a group on the r for data
science online learning community
and so it is
chat dash supply chain
and if anybody wants to join that group
i'll put the link in um
to join that flat community in the
channel or in the zoom chat too
i see federico put something in about
the book club so yeah if you i would say
those book clubs i guess i'll give a
shout out to the i want to get a shout
out to the book club's really good way
to kind of discuss with like-minded
individuals different modeling
um
you know techniques especially if you
don't have somebody in your organization
that is also doing this kind of stuff or
if you're working remotely and you know
it's a nice way to connect with
like-minded uh individuals
definitely
um and i i did just put my linkedin
there too feel free if
if anybody has any other follow-up
questions or wants to connect to connect
there or share your own linkedins and
then the chat to to network with each
other
also somebody had asked if it was okay
to share an open job posting in the
this chat channel as well
and definitely so if anybody on the call
is hiring for
supply chain professionals please feel
free to share that there too
and thank you federica for putting the
link to
the book club too
can i ask one question uh i don't worry
yeah so my question is that how uh you
how any organization utilize the
customer sentiment
to uh
forecast or
demand forecast for supply chain
analysis
how any organization utilizes it
may i ask what may ask what industry
you're in
uh consumer packaged goods or durable
goods um
i mean are you talking about maybe
getting a are you talking about cus like
a government data index where i think
there are it's been a while since i did
economic consulting but i think there
are um
uh
data uh
that you can download sentiment so i
mean you could download that data i
think there's probably some art packages
that could do that and put it
as a predictor in your model
um that's something i think maybe you
could if you really want to be creative
uh and you had surveys from your own
customers maybe you could construct some
kind of index that you read in that
survey data and assigned a numerical
waiting you could you know
uh use that or other kind of feedback
from
perhaps a website or something else i'm
not i haven't worked in consumer
packaged goods for several years so it's
i'm not super
um up on whatever might be the new
techniques but those are a couple ideas
that come to my mind
laura
um i do i vasilios i did see your hand
was raised so i'd love to just have that
be the last question too if you want to
jump in
hi thank you rachel and thank you both
to ralph and laura for great
presentations um so just a very quick
question uh
why to anyone who's actually you know
relevant to the subject um have you also
used have you also measured bias to
optimize your forecasts or just accuracy
measures and if you did like
how you know how did you do that uh in r
outside of r
just some basics
yeah yeah i think and i think you might
i think i missed that question the chat
earlier so thank you for asking that we
do measure bias um
well we have so the bias for i think
perhaps many of you on the call know
this but it's basically the variance
over the demand so from all the
variances so that is basically
directionally do you under forecast or
over forecast it's actually a big point
of discussion right now for our
commercial partners for staff forecasts
be more focused on accuracy but um yeah
if you have the data and how we
we use a lot of except my co-workers use
a lot of excel
spreadsheets these giant spreadsheets
that um hey it is what it is so i work
with that open up open
xlsx say that five times fast is a great
package but i can write that data in and
we do track it
and it's important because i think a lot
of times people do get focused on
accuracy and then um actually i've seen
that one of our one of our divisions and
they
they have they have this consistent bias
but they're like well we're accurate
we're only like five percent mape you
know or weighted maps like we're great
ones like well there's some inventory
building up there um so yes that is
really important to do and you should be
able if you have very absolute variance
you might have created a variance um
field so you could potentially use that
and just calculate your bias at the same
time
thank you so much and
thank you all so much for joining i just
don't want anyone to feel like you have
to stay around but if you want to hang
out with us all and maybe just chat
informally
feel free to stay on i just want to say
thank you so much to ralph and laura for
your awesome presentations
[Music]